good news everyone batman arkham knight
the hottest thing to be made an unreal
engine since 2014's goat simulator is
getting the playstation 4 limited
edition treatment yes we're just 449 of
your america dollars you can nab
yourself this rather sexy 500 gigabyte
playstation 4 which comes with a batman
arkham knight faceplate and matching
dualshock 4 wireless controller in steel
gray oh yes and a copy of the game if
that's too costly for your liking then
fee or not you can also have a regular
black console with a copy of the game
for only 399 of your Washington bucks
both versions will also be available in
the UK although helpfully there's no
official UK price for the limpid edition
as of yet but expected it cost you
around 350 Queen pounds the Batman
Arkham Knight console joins a growing
list of limited edition PlayStation 4
consoles including the 20th anniversary
version cycle break final fantasy type-0
and god eater 2 so are you excited to
get your hands on the official batman
arkham knight limited edition console
and what other games would you like to
see get this treatment personally i'd
like to see what they would do with noby
noby boy what that's a real game look it
up anyway let me know what you think in
the comments down below and for more
news come on back to get spot
you